hi guys it's really tasty producer I
love cooking I love baking and I love
eating last time you guys saw me making
a cake using 30 hops this time my friend
Annie collected 20 more hacks today we
are making chocolate chip cookies this
is our tone travolta cookie this is very
classic basic chocolate chip cookie it's
a little bit cakey for my taste my
favorite one a little bit crunchy
outside and soft inside let's get
started
puck number one use bread flour instead
of using all-purpose flour so bread
flour contains more protein than
all-purpose flour that creates more
gluten that means your cookie is become
more chewy
which i like you are using spoon instead
of scooping flour out and little flour I
don't get the point of just scooping
with spoon maybe if you had a narrower
flour jar scrape if you have a knife
maybe it's easier I will use this hack
for sure but not the spoon part our
instant coffee to have some java effect
July fact one teaspoon of instant coffee
to have like nice bitterness I don't
want to give too much caffeine for the
little child I'm being mom so we will
check back later
whenever I see sweet baby moves around
so I have a feeling my baby it's gonna
have a sweet tooth too
more butter hot we want to bring back
cold butter to room temperature this is
kind of a struggle I sometimes have like
I decided to bake something you need a
room-temperature butter this is a quick
way of doing it you are going to put
butter in a bag
and just people would hate me if I'm the
neighbor doing this right it's still
cold about maybe we're gonna leave it
like I feel like you will need at least
30 minutes I have another butter half so
we're gonna just sit outside and just
put butter inside
I was afraid water to get into the
wrapper but it seems like it's sealed
well it'll make sure water is not too
hard because if the water is a little
too hot it will just melt you want to
turn it every so often already feel like
it's becoming soft there has been 10
minutes let's see oh yeah nice and soft
this one let's see these are all so soft
the water gets in a little bit though
but inside it's still cold and a little
hard I like this house better according
to this hug we can combine white sugar
with more assess and just add little by
little until your desired color I have
brown sugar at home I don't have more
office at home raise your hand if you
have molasses around in your pantry
it all smells more offices Malathi it's
kind of like a slime tutorial it's
almost looked like like brown sugar
right now I like a little darker so I'm
gonna add more office texture and color
it's exactly look like a brown sugar I
have regular brown sugar let's see the
taste tastes like brown sugar and this
it's the DIY one tastes exactly like
brown sugar so this Hawk definitely
works
bring back X to room temperature winds
warm water when you're baking we want to
make sure everything is room temperature
it's like
and you can touch it it's like a good
shower so three minutes is up and we are
going to check I think it's not cold
anymore if the egg gets really cold it's
more farm but this is kind of loose now
this is room-temperature chocolate hot
do you guys remember chocolate rain
turns out it happens thirteen years ago
I don't use chocolate chip when I make
chocolate chip cookie I also use
chocolate bar you can control the size
it's looks more rustic than round
chocolate chips
so you can use knife physics in room
temperature so it doesn't have any
problem okay so I chopped all the
chocolate this aside so we have all the
ingredients ready deceits the
room-temperature butter we made it
earlier
I liked this huh Collier now I'm sure I
need one more stick butter so I'm
combining 3/4 cup of white sugar and 3/4
cup of brown sugar so we are using bread
flour and brown sugar both components
makes a little bit chewy our cookies we
are going to cream these two together so
instead of using vanilla extract using
maple syrup I'm not sure about this hack
you are kind of adding extra sweetness
chocolate chip cookies already three I
feel like if you don't have vanilla
extract just skip it we'll see I'm going
to cream about five minutes so this is
nice consistency and I'm adding egg one
by one I'm going to add flour mixture so
for the cookie shorter the mixed time
it's better especially we are using
bread flour as well and there it's no
flour visible so I'm gonna stop right
here and I'm going to mix chocolate all
right
so though it's ready next hot we are
going to use cookie dough as a glue
you're using convection over especially
there it's a whole air coming from the
oven
sometimes like paper just flew away I
use this all the time it doesn't need to
be cookie you can use this for macaroons
so this is a good hug it's ice cream
scooper I also use this hack all the
time for baking cookie cause you can
portion control and also creates nice
rustic shapes using ice tray for
leftover dough and you can freeze them
I'm not sure about this huh you can
maybe scoop on a tray with ice cream
scoop and freeze it probably for like
saving space I would just scoop it and
put it in a ziploc bag so I'm going to
rest this dough for overnight I think
you guys ought to be so Alvin's two days
cookie recipe video you want to at least
risk this dough overnight or as alden
data two days kind of makes it better
flavor it's almost like curing you can
freeze the dough so it doesn't spread
too much but if you're resting this
dough overnight you don't need to freeze
it so I'm going to just put it in a
refrigerator and I just see you guys
tomorrow
okay we've rested this dough overnight
add more chocolate chip before you bake
it I think this happens just give more
chocolate chip pie I think we are doing
this because the chocolate chip is more
visible I might use it but I'm not gonna
get a chocolate chip I'm gonna use
roughly chop the chocolate use flaky
salt this flaky salt it's good addition
for chocolate chip cookie because
chocolate chip cookie is very sweet so
it's kind of cut and balance out the
sweetness
[Music]
use muffin pain for perfect circle we're
going to spray the muffin pain it's kind
of like a mold you know so you're going
to put cookies in a muffin ting it
doesn't spread out it's intact I like
the doors like rustic shape so I'm not
gonna get this hot I think it's just a
preference thing another muffin tin huh
you are using muffin tin upside down to
make kind of a cookie ball so you can
put ice cream in there I wonder if it's
gonna spread if you want to maintain the
cookie shape you want to cook higher
temperature and shorter time so I'm
going to cook this 375 about 8 to 10
minutes all right
so those are ready this is the one we
bake in a muffin tin I know like a like
a flat muffin cookie muffin cooking I
don't know what it's the benefit of you
can see my fainting so this is another
muffin tin hock it spread kinda look
like a jellyfish and I know okay so this
is what we got the recipe we used they
don't work I think it's like 60 percent
successful use waffle maker Oh
the reason it's smoky I put oil earlier
this like make cookie waffle so cook you
upwards cool let's see why it's gonna do
it's coming out oh no oh yeah yeah Wow
wait how are you gonna pick this out
it's breaking No
me too I think cookie dough doesn't have
a enough structure or enough flour to
keep the shape No so the original Nestle
Toll House cookie recipe it's fake us
375 about 8 to 10 minutes so it's a
little bit taller and inside it's a
little bit more hekia and this is a la
we've baked 350 for 10 to 12 minutes
edge its crispy and it's chewy inside
the most fun part tasting the texture
it's great flavor it's great
I have some sort of like aftertaste
maybe it's the maple syrup I don't like
this afternoon it is so much today
overall I like hot cookie better than
the control cookie because the texture I
like salt and instant coffee kind of
gives nice touch so I think this is a
winner we have one last hug if you burn
cookie in the bottom you can just grade
it so it's not bitter so you can use
either cheese grater or micro prying
just like generally great so you don't
need to do this away all right
we used all 20 hacks and we are done
here it's three hats I like from today's
experiment brown sugar hock warming up
egg huh resting Doha hot sauce
[Music]